[Music]
hey
[Applause]
yeah the new kids on the block hit the
music scene in the 80s and they've been
hanging tough ever since now the band is
bringing all of its hits to las vegas as
part of its mixtape tour and joining us
now via zoom is longtime band member
danny wood danny thanks for joining us
today
well thanks for having me i'm really
excited about the upcoming show there in
vegas you know you did a similar tour in
2019 is this the first time because of
everything that's going on that
everybody's had a chance to get back
together
yeah i mean you know it was a rough
couple years and um you know we weren't
able to work much so this is you know
the first tour we've been able to put
together since the pandemic so it's the
mixtape tour 2022.
you have stayed plenty busy over the
years uh you ran a marathon i guess
eight years ago and did quite well you
finished in under four hours
yeah it was the one and only one i'm
probably ever gonna do i ran boston
me and
joe mack also from the group we both ran
it and um
both did pretty good and that's it i'm a
retired marathon runner hey pretty good
is an understatement first of all the
boston marathon is one of the toughest
so that you did that one's pretty
impressive
it was it was tough
that was in memory of your mom and did i
get that right
yeah i have a foundation that helps
breast cancer patients and my mom passed
away in 1999 so
keep our memory alive and we raise money
for you know breast cancer patients all
across the country i love that you've
been doing that the band is amazing in a
lot of ways and one of the things i
noticed is
most of it is made up of original band
members with the exception of some guy
named mark wahlberg and whatever
happened to him i don't know
but you guys have stayed together
yeah i mean part of what makes us unique
is we knew each other before we became a
band four of us knew each other me
jordan john and donnie all went to the
same elementary school and then me and
donny continued on through high school
together so i think that friendship you
know that the base of that is a lot of
the reasons we've been able to stay
together i love that because there are
so many stories unlike that one where
bands break up and maybe one or two
original members are still a part of
what's going on today so that's really
cool what makes that unique is it
because of
the connection that you had beforehand
or just the chemistry and jill in
general
i think we just know each other a lot
better than maybe other bands would and
we um we compromise you know and in the
end
it's always what we do on stage for the
fans is what's most important so we tend
to always agree on that kind of stuff
and try to strive to make each tour
better than the last one absolutely love
it when did you know that new kids on
the block was
making it that you were no longer just
friends from high school that you were
actually a band that was
taking the world by storm
i think when we released right stuff as
our second single um
and we were going on tour for a second
time um with tiffany
and
we were still opening for her like the
summer before
but after the first show you could kind
of tell
it needed to be kind of reversed and
um you know we everything took off from
there and it's incredible because you
have man maintained a fan base uh all
these many years and the reception is
very warm including the one you have
coming up here at mandalay bay how
invigorating is that and and how good
does it feel that you still have such a
following
well we we now have categories of fans
like you have the og blockheads who are
the original
you know people that have been with us
since the 80s and now you have the
second generation blockheads maybe girls
that
are in their
early twenties that came to our you know
the reunion in 2008 and now you have the
baby blockheads they're like
you know between eight and fourteen
and there's just a lot of them out in
the crowd so we're just lucky to still
be doing this after all these years and
you have some legendary guests uh coming
with you on this tour
yeah we have involved salt and pepper
and rick ashley and
in vogue and song pepper have never
toured together and every night i get to
watch them do what a man
together
is like a highlight of the show
well i know so many people are looking
forward to it danny thanks so much for
joining us today and good luck with all
of the tour
thank you thank you for having me new
kids on the block bringing the mixtape
tour 2022 featuring salt and pepper rick
astley in vogue as legendary special
guest comes to mickelove ultra arena at
mandalay bay this sunday rocky the